I've always been kind of a doodler and a
drawer two years ago when I was working
at an agency in the city I made my CEO a
pair of sneakers it kind of grew from
there
I always was this female thinker and
creator in this male space that I said
to myself why can't the two be together
[Music]
being connected on Instagram and online
has enhanced my work my visibility and
it's enhanced my ability to collaborate
[Music]
the questionnaire really simplifies the
way that I design it's essentially
things that I would naturally ask a
friend of mine if I were designing their
sneakers when I start drawing on a
sneaker I like to incorporate the curves
into my work rather than trying to fit
in a certain design within a certain
space what I love about art and about
the sneaker world in general is that
it's colorful its energetic it has to do
with sport but it also has to do with
aesthetics but I think that people
really remember my work because they see
this unique hybrid and it resonates with
a lot of people
[Music]
taking small steps towards your goals
can have a huge impact taking little
steps to where you want to go is way
better than not trying at all
you